but as a project blue labor inside the
labor party full of in a half a million
momentum middle-class trots it's not
going to work they're not gonna get a
blue labor platform so it's a small
group and then and then you had Philip
blonds project which is red Tory again
which we like aspects of it there are
differences with us of this relatively
small differences but again
Tory's flow with it but the modern Tory
is basically some sort of free-market
liberal hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constance and kissing and this is a show
if you're bored of people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guests this week is the
leader of the Social Democratic Party
will in please and welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me kind
of you testable
[Music]
thanks for coming my first question
always is what is the story of your life
how are you where you are what's been
your journey through life that takes you
home is check right well I was born in
the northeast of England mother's from
Edinburgh fathers from Liverpool he's a
red nose we my father's involved in
politics a little bit in the Labour
Party in an era when 1980 came along and
the the big split from the Labour Party
mean the Social Democratic Party is a an
offshoot of the Labour Party
my dad left the Labour Party and joined
and it was a very exciting time for us
as a family and also too just to see
that the launch of a new thing it was
also quite hostile I mean they had open
meetings in the northeast and you know
lice of David Owen came up to speak and
there be a lot of labour people in there
heckling but you've seen the videos in
70s politics eighties politics quite
raucous but it was interesting and it
captivated me I joined and we went
through the period of of seeing that
blossom into the Alliance and 83 the the
big election for us where we got with
the Liberals 20
twenty five and a half percent of the
vote that was the biggest the SDP
represents the biggest attempt to date
for a hundred years basically to break
the political mold to change the
two-party system that's what it was set
up to do and have to say failed and
that's one of the reasons were still
still here plugging away so yeah that
was that was my initial background and
involve them well let's let's talk about
something that we've discussed at length
on the show with many guests in the past
is we've talked about the fact that
there seems to be a gap in the market so
to speak for a party that is socially
conservative but left-wing so one of the
arguments John Curtis made for example
is the new Kipp under Nigel Farage it
was a party that was trying to be
socially conservative but he was also
right-wing in terms of many of its
policies yeah and its voters were not
right so there's potentially a gap in
the market for a party that is socially
conservative that wants to control
immigration that wants to be you know
expressing their socially conservative
values while being left-wing is that you
it's exactly us and no one else is doing
it and one of the reasons I think people
ask us why after the I mean cuz to
finish off the sort of history lesson on
the SDP you had the overnight SDP which
I was involved in that was when the
Liberals you know they had a deal to put
the pot two parties together some of 42
percent of us voted against that because
we're so Democrats and the reason for
that is that social democracy and
liberalism is different philosophically
very different actually first order
preference in liberalism to the
individual but we have we think that in
a society in the community exists and is
at least as important and so Owen Owens
STP went there and then in 1980 he
clears clears off and the party gets
kicked back to the grassroots but it
exists and you have very strong pockets
in the East Yorkshire and South Wales
Glasgow and Midlands but it's a bit I
think it's a bit like a bird species
where you have total coverage when the
when the when the species is strong and
then it gets not back and then you end
up in pockets and that's where we were
so this gap in that the political gap in
the market I think partly explains why
the enduring SDP is as just sprung up
from the grassroots because people look
at the political landscape and they say
well you know what have we who can we
vote for positively and they look and
there are problems I mean I guess the
remain of Parliament is an example of a
problem where a widely held view is not
well represented in Parliament so you
have a misalignment there but there's a
lot of it and I think this you know the
two-party system is seen to fail now
because you know it's it's it's its
biggest selling point was it create a
stability well there's no stability I do
think we well governed either so there
is a there is a but on the particular
type of politics the sort of red and
blue politics that you're talking about
yeah there isn't another entity but us
that's doing it which it explains why
we've got thousands of members joining
and while we're growing all around the
country because we're the only people
are doing it now obviously you have
think tanks and academics and even even
movements like blue labour Morris
classmen thing which I like a lot I mean
I think there's very very little
difference there are tiny little
differences between us and and them I
guess but as a project blue labor inside
the Labour Party full of in there half a
million momentum middle-class trots not
going to work they're not gonna get a
blue labor platform so it's a small
group and then and then you had Philip
Blondes project which is red Tory again
which we we like aspects of it there are
differences but there are so this
relatively small differences but again
Tory's flow with it but the modern Tory
is basically some sort of free-market
liberal you know so if you were gonna
outline who you are to a potential voter
how would you describe your party we're
we're sort of red and blue pluralists
really we you know how you know when you
meet I'm gonna do this slowly now have
you yeah you ask me do quickly but it's
you know you meet people at a party
might meet someone and and people's
political views tend to cluster but many
many people don't fall into that
and you know when you meet someone you
know they'll say one they'll say
something like even if you're in the
States I'll say that you know for gun
control and then you can you can derive
all their other views from it yeah and
the same happens here well actually
that's probably behalf the country are
satisfied with I'm a red or I'm a blue
but actually about half a country isn't
and half of the country have views which
cut across those things in different
domains and so and that's legitimate but
it's not but it's not something our
political system can represent well and
it doesn't represent well because we've
got a red party in the blue party I mean
they're there nowadays that they're both
types of liberals and actually which is
another problem
but but so this this idea if I was going
to explain it quickly center-left on
economics and public services center
right or small see conservative on
social and cultural issues that's it and
so I mean we touched on what happened
with UK how much of a danger is a brexit
party to your potential voter base that
the the Nigel Farage's brags a party now
yes well that's that's a sort of that's
an immediate question because this
project is about convening people who
agree with with us we had a look at the
philosophy of the party last year and
and we wrote this thing called the new
Declaration which is a sort of
philosophical platform and we've urged
people to read it if you like it join us
and if you don't don't join us don't you
know cuz actually there's a lot of
people's who are you know a sort of
free-market liberals no thanks it's not
what we do so you know we agree with the
long brags it but that's it
the so on on on on the brexit party
thing that's that's going to play out
over the next three months six months or
whatever but actually it's it's another
single issue Nigel Faraj vehicle and the
problem with you Kip historically always
was there was a ceiling there was a
ceiling on how far they could go because
it was basically about you know your
skepticism and it you know and inside
that group you had I mean the word the
worst centrist
economic left even individuals like
Patrick O'Flynn who came and joined our
party who were in the tank because they
were good
you're skeptics but Nigel will always
have the problem that it's a single
issue I mean either the name you know
there's a single issue thing um you know
the SDP is is very you're a skeptic but
if you read the new declarations a month
about four four little paragraphs on
nation and world and your skepticism and
the rest of it is about also a lot of
stuff and I don't think I think Nigel
Faraj will do very well in the cellar I
mean they could win the euro election if
it happens but a suit remember as soon
as there's a deal if there's a deal it's
over I mean that's that as a political
entity what we can do then you have to
change your name anyway yeah so so I
don't know I mean we sort of left and
also tactically we it was very unfair
for the government to spring an election
their elections on a small party I mean
also more parties ago so there's meat we
looked at it and our National Committee
looked at in came to a decision a I'm an
instinctive the I I wasn't happy with
you know electing Euro let you know and
peace to the Europe all we voted out
what we're doing so I was against there
anyway and then to spring an election on
us we could have we could we had the
resources to have candidates all over
the country but we'd get a couple of
percent and what's the point so we just
said no we're gonna sit this one out
and I think a lot of our voters will
probably vote break the party actually
but I haven't I mean I'm not directed to
do that they can do that for like many
will so that's the voice that you
represent this is you said small see
conservatives so let's look at some of
the principles that you talked about
liberalism being the dominant strain of
thought in Parliament and maybe in
society in general what is your issue
with liberalism um to go back to what I
said before I think it I think the basic
problem is philosophically it just
privileges individual rights too much I
mean we're all for it meanwhile we are
liberal but we're not liberals I mean a
lot of a lot of SDP positions are quite
nuanced so we're very Pro European
culturally very but we're not breaking
on the year we're liberal but we're not
two liberals and I think the prong with
the project the whole so do emancipate
grand liberalisation project that we've
had since the 60s is that we've ended up
with a society and many fellow citizens
agree with this where me me me I come
first so the economic liberalism it's
all about getting as much money as I can
and getting ahead as far ahead as other
people as I can and the social
liberalism is about individual
emancipation what are my rights you know
how am I going to prosecute those rights
against the whole of the rest of the
society and demand I want this all in
there now all of those things up to a
point it's I mean I think David good
hearts right about this
I think in looking about liberalism
looking at liberalism in terms of
overreach have we got to a stage where
there is simply too much
mimimi and not enough us and I think
we're there honestly I think we're there
I think the the appeal of communitarian
parties now not not in the elites you
see the and there is a there's a very
big gap between what academics you know
but basically what what the Academy
Business the media think is is basically
full-on liberalism and as possible as
much as possible you know with both
barrels and David again David good
hearts a great thinker on on this this
this idea of double-dose liberalism see
societies had you know 30 years of
socialism liberalism bang-bang-bang so
anyone that speaks up with other
families you can't do that when already
counted with that
it's an individualism all the time and
then eka and then at the same time
you've got the free-market liberals of
the right who hammer basically public
services have to be contracted out so
everything becomes marketized
every literally everywhere and at the
same time that the the state has lost
confidence to actually just directly
provide services and retain what should
be its its its domain I mean a key an
absolutely key I'd say the cornerstone
social and economic idea and the SDP is
the social market economy which is
something that we introduced in British
politics in the 80s and what's still
there
absolutely that is the
the cornerstone idea and that's the idea
that the the state and the market are
not opponents do you think we've reached
this point now where you sort of alluded
to it where the pendulum is swinging
back against liberalism yeah yeah and I
think it is I think it is and I think
always that you can certainly see that I
mean if you take immigration
you know we're Pro immigration but we I
don't think we're pro mass immigration I
think and all and again but what does
that mean a lot of people will even make
the distinction well magnitude matters
so an Academical paul molitor came out
of the book about migration very
recently and he made a point that in the
peak of the new labor immigration
expansion more people came to settle in
the UK than had ever arrived between
1066 and 1950 you know it could be a
million million people and that's that's
that's that's very high immigration now
again if you look at what the general
public think the general public and even
leave voters by the way a eighty-five
percent of them are quite Pro
immigration they're happy with it as
long as it's it's basically of the right
scale now again to in the southeast
we're sitting here in Islington to fail
to have that much immigration and fail
to do the other side of the tennis net
which is to build enough council houses
and yes council houses not to be sold
off the state actually doing something
to help young people meet you know pair
up and start thinking about raising a
family again the the economic liberals
oh we don't do that it's all left to the
market well actually they're just
misaligned with the public the public
want the state to help in in housing and
you cut on any millennial in then
there's in the southeast it's completely
in favor of the state to thaw them out
how you're gonna get anywhere to live so
it's a lot of these things interlocked
then they so you can have what I'm
saying is you can have massive you can
have very very high rates of immigration
and you might get away with it if the
states pick pick you know it picks the
the other side of it up and assist it
but they haven't done that either but
the thing I just want to clarify this
thing of how you someone can be because
I think I understand
what you mean but I'm not sure that
everybody will you say you're Pro
immigration and what does that mean like
you're not against immigrants
oh no no yeah I mean there's a
distinction I mean that that's a
distinction anyway I mean yeah we live
in an open and tolerant society yeah and
all the data across Europe this is one
of the most tolerant societies thank you
absolutely you're not allowed to say
that anyway so nobody recently
immigrants understand it you know yeah
they do because it is a nice place to
live and people are cool and people we
get on and that's the reality
no on my on the magnitude you've just
got to get your immigration rate right
the other side on immigration which I
think probably liberals have slightly
overstepped is that so they've been I
think liberalism has been too
enthusiastic for very high levels of
immigration and I think it's been too
indifferent to integration yeah again I
think that is a that as a mainstream
view we I'd like to talk about in
centrism later
what is centrism so i we we what we're
representing and very very mainstream
views on the data you know so most
people most British people comfortable
with a degree of multiculturalism but
they're they're like separatist
multiculturalism very much and they do
think people we ought to have common
values which which bind us together in
some way and if we don't actually as a
society we simply won't succeed I mean
what you sound what you're saying to me
sounds eminently reasonable I agree with
it and I think yep okay it we're making
a lot of sense here however there is the
other side to it sort of the David Lammy
left who says that you know that this
you know talking about immigration in
this way is akin to you know Nazism or
whatever else and all this I'm not sure
what's going on with that at the moment
really note it genuinely it's it's quite
it's quite strange because because this
has bubbled up recently and I mean the
rhetoric the after the 2016 vote the
establishment hammered the vote
yeah it literally killed it disparaged
it said lots of nasty things which
weren't true you know or levers I mean
II remember what a broad coalition this
was 52 percent of the public and assets
of racist vote is absurd you you run out
of racists really quickly on the data
it's true about there about four percent
of this society's racist and bigoted on
the figures four or five depending what
question you ask but you can't say the
half of the public that voted on
democracy voted on that basis nonsense
so the rhetoric has gone gone a little
crazy I don't know what and I don't
think it's helpful either because I
think it's another thing in the SDP that
we're against we're for tolerance but we
the the sort of identity politics
intersectional stuff that is hammered by
that by the far left or even the coffin
left actually which isn't really far
left this is very left
hammering differences literally 24 hours
constantly hammering differences I'm
different that that is going to lead to
division and I think instead politicians
ought to think about what unites people
most most people no matter what your
background or religion is one same
things it's interesting that you say
that this division because I've just
been away for a couple of weeks to to
form a part of the Soviet Union and it's
amazing to me just coming back and
starting talk because I tried to switch
off from the mirror and stuff like that
everyone's coming back and just going
wait someone's just being called white
or someone's being called a man or
someones bit like as if that's a
legitimate argument and I think that's
where we've we've kind of come to it's
crazy and it's I think it I think it is
actually a type of what we're witnessing
is a type of mania literally among some
commentators and some social justice or
is I think it's a type of mania people
are going crazy and they need that
people need a little bit of perspective
most people get on you know out there in
the real world we get on and it's not to
try and constantly see everything as a
sort of rights violation risk it's an
odd very old frame mind it's not I
certainly know healthy is but it's not
accurate either that's the odd thing
about it it's funny in philosophy you
get these waves waves of movements in
thought and you know communism or you
know what
but in philosophy there was a movement
logical positivism in the in the
thirties a Jer wrote a book
and a Vienna circle and it was all about
scientific rationalism being able to
sort of put the put the ground floor to
justify any any any of you had to be had
to be grounded you know an infill
departments around particularly in the
Anglo world in America and in here
undergraduates be running around anyone
that said anything
you know another graduate pinning
someone against the walls there well how
are you going to verify that and and
this is this of course the movement just
went through and actually they
discovered I mean popper demonstrates
you can't verify anything any was the
whole thing was clapped out and it's
quite discredited I mean it did have I
quite like parts of it but it's one of
these movements that just sort of
started and then it became very intense
and then just faded away and I think
probably again there's been there's been
liberal overreach but there's been sort
of parity mania social justice overreach
and craziness and I think we just have
to go just ride it out I guess because
you can't become like any like any
movement of that kind it'll it'll it'll
have its time and it'll say anyway
hopefully one of the things you talk
about is community yeah and I think it's
undeniable that we have lost the sense
of community in this country this is
probably happening all around the world
you know families are becoming smaller
more atomized we're living most
imporantly from each other with you're
less connected to each other you know we
don't talk to our neighbors all over the
rest of it and anyone can diagnose that
but but if you only have reasons not
this is actually a point I made in an
article once so the reason we don't talk
to our neighbors it's not because we
hate them it's just we're British that's
what we do but if we take all of that
and we kind of diagnose and we say this
is a problem and we know it's a problem
because if in terms of our mental health
for all sorts of reasons this is a big
big problem how do we fix that I think
by by switching culturally from me me me
to us and to the community and I think
it's I think this is where political
leadership
doesn't matter how we think about what
we do and what we do so community is
massively important people I mean a lot
of liberal left politicians just just
forget about it they're just completely
not interested not all of them but many
do and so that the the basic building
blocks family which is the first place
that you do something for other people
you learn that in the home I'm going to
help you know your mother will help your
father will help you and you that's the
first place that we learn it and then
going on from that our neighborhood
knowing people getting involved running
sports clubs and incense I mean this is
actually a sort of civic society stuff
that Phillip long talked about you know
I mentioned the red torii combination
and Phillips idea was that the Civic
Society does have the greatest role in
sort of cultural renewal that's right
the problem is where it's needed most
sukh society is weakest and actually
where it's maybe not needed so much it's
it's at its strongest you know so you go
to sort of a very strong relatively
affluent village and you know people
would be involved in the curricular they
all know each other and it's very very
strong serving societies and some other
areas in urban areas where you've got a
perhaps a less stable population more
people coming and going and things it's
not as strong but it's I mean it we've
either way we've got to think about
communitarian impulses and think about
doing you know working together you make
that point I mean labor and it's at its
core is communitarian wasn't what was it
was it was all about unions it was about
representing the people and you look at
the modern labor I mean it's just
demented number one and number two it's
like you said is it all about divisions
yeah I am this this and this you are
this is so destructive
especially poisons I mean it is looking
at society like that is poisonous a
philosopher I like a lot John Gray
you know people consider him a little
bit bleak and he can be bleak at times
but he's also very is a great viewer and
commentator on liberalism and you know
he's he's he's great on this you know
you how far do you go
with with individualism before the whole
of society just unravels and and on that
how far do you go in identity politics
before you you you end up with what he
describes as a sort of low intensity
civil war and that's you know people
want that you know and I think you know
you can talk in slogans but we the SDP
idea is a social future and it must be
it's either that or gated communities
yeah what do you want you know but how
we didn't get there because as I sit
here doing this interview I'm enjoying
it yeah my wife's you crazy which is
very independent anyway I sit here and
I'm thinking I really like this guy he's
a nice guy
he has interesting ideas right he he's
persuasive he says interesting things
but would I vote for him is there is
there a thing that I kind of got all
that that gets me you know I think it I
mean all all any any any program is a
balanced program so yeah you know if you
read the new declaration not everyone is
going to agree with absolutely
everything but the important thing about
the SDP is that with any people doing
this so again I mean I'll you know read
Tory blue labor their intellectual
movements really but this is this is a
proper political party grassroots up
we've got several thousand members now
and it's happening and it's happening
for the right reasons and you can you
can you know stay at home or whatever
where you could get involved or you
don't have to but I'm it's actually
happening in it and it's a real entity
in that it will be its contesting real
elections and we're trying to beat the
Labor Party and the Conservatives and
you given the others and contest for
seats to get proper representation and I
but it will take time people when you
when you are involved in a sort of
upsurge Elias everyone thinks you know
why are you want question time yet why
new I you know what and it does take
time it you know if you look at you
clips and I mean the top-down SDP was
was just like that it literally you know
foreign secretary you know film star
looks yeah David Owen was a dominant
politician wonderful politician Roy
Jenkins home sake and these are big
figures and instantly they're got
sort of instant you know I mean at one
point in 82 we're at 50 percent in the
polls but it went up like a rocket but
it came down like the stick that was the
problem and actually this time it's
grassroots so there's normal normal
participants many who haven't been in
parties before we got a lot of people in
the Labour Party with recently we've got
more concerted joining of things greens
joining in Lib Dems Euroskeptic Linda so
yeah so that's I think it'll take time
but it'll work and I think the thing
that I'm really really confident about
is the is that masse good women and the
others that do the work on the gaps
there is a gap means no one else doing
you know you do the political compass
thing and the whole of the southwest or
the bottom corner is but my challenge to
you isn't that you're too slow in
getting there my challenge is that I
don't hear anything concrete I don't
hear policies that are gonna grab my
attention or things that well build bill
council housing to hell that has a
million people how does that grab you
diagram and by the way we're gonna I we
think it's too small I could the next
policy will increase that and those
council houses won't be for sale I mean
that already grabs me because to me one
of the biggest failures of the
Conservative government is that
unwillingness to deal with the with the
housing crisis especially in London
labor as well they didn't do it no they
didn't do them yeah they didn't and it's
it's what the really strange thing about
particularly on conservatives I'm not
consumed as a good good drinking pals
bless them you know I you know I think
they they're less judgmental in the pub
and things you know get so much in your
ear but they that the problem the modern
soda but it's not conservative it's not
I mean they say you know theoretically
if they've got the guts just to back the
family as an idea
now which they don't really do now but
if they do have the guts to say that
they haven't connected that you can't
have the state just literally depart
from the field that so we're not gonna
do it
we're not going to help at all you're on
your own bye-bye that's what the
Conservatives are done and they on on
housing and if you do that it means that
people can't when they meet they can't
get a flat they can't possibly get a
house and they won't have kids and the
Conservatives theoretically a concern is
meant as poor
couples that want to do that so I would
say it's not conservative what you've
become
is free-market liberal maniacs that's
what you are because you want to market
eyes everything literally everything
even the stuff that the state should do
so they go so another policy railway
nationalization yeah it's gonna happen
anyway
you think yeah because the because you
get fewer and fewer I mean it's a Crow's
a crazy
you know confection privatization anyway
I mean no it's a crate I mean that the
state does the heavy lifting anyway with
the infrastructure about four billion
goes internet a year and then they let
that and then they let a few different
color trains run up and down on it's not
really private that you can't and no
state railway system runs at a profit no
um it's got to be efficient but it
shouldn't I mean it's it's a public
service really to get people around and
when you think about it that way the
whole project I think major did it
because he'd run out of sort of
Thatcherite credibility honestly I think
you know if you read about him that's
what happened they it's crazy and what's
happened is that the franchisees can't
make money out of it so there are fewer
bidding for it so it's just going down
and then they screw it up like the I'll
be going back to Northumberland tonight
well this afternoon on on a nationalized
Helen er train hurrah but they but that
but that that's what happens you see
when when things when the market fails
the state comes in and picks it up so
that's it is a logical thing and it will
happen it's just a matter of time I'll
give us more give us more can I ask one
question which i think is very important
but this is and I think this is very
very important and it's a crisis that we
have now in London and all our major
cities which is knife crime yeah and for
me because I'm hopefully when I get
married within the next couple of years
you want to have kids all the rest of it
I can't see myself living in a city
because I don't want my children to be
around that
how would you appeal to you know the
young people and people were about to
have families that they're going to be
able to bring up their children in
safety and it seems like every day I
open the paper and there's another kid
getting stabbed and murdered it's
desperate yeah I think I think what
we've got to do is actually be a little
bit more on
when politicians are interviewed about
knife crime they'll talk left and right
actually talk about police tactics or
police numbers you know you got the map
used to be at 33,000 were at 28 now and
there aren't enough resources and
they'll talk about other things like
that but they won't talk about any
fundamentals and I would say how about
the crisis in the family are we gonna be
honest about that that it you can't and
actually it's a bit like the the housing
thing
the sad thing on housing is that you
can't I can't say to any Millennial vote
for me because I'll solve it because it
would take 20 years to solve you
understand this yeah I mean there just
isn't you can't you can't get the house
at the public housing stock up in in
five years ten years or even 15 it's a
whole generation but knife crime and all
these other things you have to go back
to to sort of parenting and community
unfortunately that is the reality and I
think if people have strong role models
and the societies with them back to the
communitarian thing then you in the long
run then knife crime would would reduce
it would but be you but that's not
something that a politician can say I
can solve now by shoving this amount of
money on it
or doing that I mean they're left
particularly one of the one one of the
criticisms which the SDP has of the
current Labor Party is that it views
cultural issues cultural problems just
through the lens of money I mean it's a
bore you hear listen to them interviewed
and they just say cuts cuts cuts
well not all our proms ah are caused by
you know Tory cuts I mean we I mean the
SOB isn't from in favor of a strong an
active state you need it you need you
know state spending all about 41 percent
of GDP and and that's much higher than
the Tories who wanted but it's not a
sizable calling one but you can't they
have a tendency to blame cultural proms
on money and actually that a lot of the
solutions and and not to do with money
either one of my favorite things is
another policy is the daily model you
know the daily mind and have you heard
of that no no so there's a school in
Stirling in in Scotland and and the the
Health metrics for the kids was not what
was not brilliant weren't fit weren't
concentrating and the head teacher there
said right we're gonna do a
communitarian thing
every kid and all the staff all the
teachers we're gonna run a mile every
day all of us together no excuses no ops
outs we're all gonna do it different
speeds but but you know they're gonna do
it and they did that they started off
doing it was a cost its cost nothing to
be fair they had you know then there are
issues with with with where could you do
it car but they did it and all literally
the education outcomes increased the
health outcomes increased all the data
in you know is fantastic
now didn't cost anything and that's a
cultural solution to it to a health and
education issue so it's a voluntary
thing we were a bit and a comment what
the pickup is something like forty forty
percent of primary schools do this now
and it's a sort of team building and
community building thing we were a
little bit scared of saying right you
know this Social Democrats on mandate
this is when you mandate stuff it all
goes wrong but but it's an example of
something where honestly culture is I
mean we're all aware of the fact that
politics has taken a cultural turn in
the last ten years twenty years you know
in the left and right thing about
economics which it was just about who
gets what and what the state should do I
think that's still important actually I
really do I think that's very important
but culture is number one no that's it
and I think so cultural cultural
solutions to cultural problems is what I
would say long-term it's just an
interesting such a good point isn't it
because one of the things I hear as I
listen to you and then I compare that
with a lot of things that a politician
might say on a on question time wherever
else is we no longer seem to have any
understanding that some problems take
time to solve exactly and we've become
so impatient as a society that we don't
want to hear your answer that no we do
not want to hear that we don't want to
be told this isn't gonna get solved in
15 years yeah it's the same it's the
same as the the undergraduate full
student pinning someone down about very
tell me now tell me now what you're
gonna do well know some of the things do
take I mean will take a long time and
you know that that is the way it is and
I think the people people are ready for
that on they it was also to do with our
pile
mentoree system that you get elected for
four years yeah if you actually stay
well look I'm not gonna solve this in
four years and everyone thinks well what
am I gonna vote for you then I'm gonna
vote for ya you know whoever is over
here saying that you can solve it in two
yeah no I agree with that but on the
other hand that the you know the public
is much more switched on than
politicians
imagine and actually the whole brexit
vote in there you know the coining of
phrases heartbreak the soft brags a
crash and all that you know the public
of whether aware of what's going on they
know these are slogans I mean they're
not that really really not you spend a
bit of time on the doorsteps people know
what's happening so yeah and I think
people people would be ready for a
longer term thing but I think that that
the short-termism of British politics is
partly to do with another thing which
you've talked about to other
participants which is for the duopoly
and the first-past-the-post voting
system which is which is it's finished
it's cooked it needs I mean I think one
of the consequences we we are living
through a political crisis now no doubt
strange you're not really an economic
one really you know full employment you
know it's odd this I mean at you know in
the in the world outside things continue
in the countries doing reasonably well
but there's a political crisis and I
think what are that what are they're
going to be the consequences of that and
I think the I would put money on the
consequence being the duopoly
first-past-the-post it's going to go
people weren't because I don't think
people are going to put up with the
status quo politics as usual they're not
to put up with them and that's what
you're gonna get if the voting system
doesn't change so when do you think it's
gonna change do you think it's gonna be
I know it's impossible to make
predictions alright within 10 years
we'll have we'll have the new voting
system it might be amazing yeah I think
with it and that's and that's being
optimistic but I think it would happen I
just don't think people I think within I
by the way I don't there's gonna be an
election a time soon I think you're
gonna go to three years from now because
they I mean we're in sort of late 70s
you know Wilson Callaghan Lib lab pact
so now we they won't a government won't
call an election it'll lose or a thinks
it will lose so I just think we're just
going to go to the bitter end
but I don't know if it's that election
or the election after but what you need
to have to break it is actually a ground
line
every single party that wants PR for one
election greens you know Communist Party
of Britain practice martial artists
Leninist you know the whole know you
need it you need a one election we've
had enough thing because I think people
have had enough and you look at you look
at the future yet more the same really I
mean the thing about first-past-the-post
was it used to they used to say it
delivered strong government and ability
and stability and also firm decisions I
mean you know firm election results well
it hasn't done that I mean it doesn't
literally it is clapped out it really I
mean the whole constitutional thing
needs are looking at but I I don't think
that's gonna survive I uh and I think
the number of people that are pulling
away from the main parties and their
allegiances are pulling away I mean you
know working-class voters with the
modern Labour Party it's not a good fit
and people and people started voting you
Kip novo I mean they're very interesting
actually at the last election twenty
seventeen was the first time that the
Tories had as many votes as the Labour
Party did you know that no yeah so the
they used to be class but very class but
based routing if you go back to the to
the fifties very very you know
working-class block you know and so you
had that and then and then there's been
a sort of gradual realignment from that
but it's it's quickened and actually the
next election I would predict I think
this one is probably do terribly but
they they all have quite a strong
working-class vote and it's one of these
realignments where you know you like if
you look at American politics now and
you know the southern states are
Republican and you say to kids well you
know that used to be Democrat
what really I mean they're quite racist
Democrats yeah actually yeah which is
what there was a problem but they but a
proper realignment happened in the
sixties under Lyndon Johnson and you
can't imagine that now yeah and people
can say well hey what is something sex
with vending Democrat yeah they were
solid absolutely solid and when you're
going through it you sort of don't
notice it but it's happening and I think
so I think it's very odd the
Conservatives how they've played Briggs
it they the Conservative Party they say
is the most successful political party
in the world and it is because it
changes you know used to be
protectionist then it's free trading and
it's free to throughout the years it
just changes and morphs um became the
business party used to be the heiress
those party and so on and they had a
they have a massive opportunity right
now to pick up the ball own breaks it
dunno deal and get and convene a totally
new conservative thing and it actually
if they were socially conservatives they
storm it they're not doing it this is
well they're afraid of losing half the
I'm terrified yeah well yeah but the
misalignment there isn't this with the
parliamentarians it's not with the it's
not with the membership or their voters
actually is weird because they because I
think the parliamentarians and the
bigwigs have actually played this wrong
but I mean I'm no coach to the Tory
party some today what they do but they
they've missed a massive opportunity for
a for a full-on realignment because
they'd have taken the the leave
working-class vote they wouldn't how
dangerous is it do you think that
essentially the conservatives and labour
have turned their back on traditional
working-class Heartland and essentially
what you have now is a large swath of
those people
yeah well I'm represented I think it's
very dangerous it's it's it's it's not a
good thing for not only a social class
but a viewpoint actually to be
persistently ignored to be persistently
ignored you surround proms is like a
pressure cooker you've got to come out
in other words and it actually Peter
shor who's probably my favorite my
physical hero wrote very well on this if
you ignore if you don't allow
participation and democracy to deal with
these things you'll get a bit
disobedience in the end or outright
even or worse basically well there's no
issue there is no issue that is divided
I think the the country more on that
basis where people haven't been
represented and their views haven't been
taken into account in an immigration
yeah I don't think there's a single
issue then we were never asked that's
what they all say right yeah so so what
is what is your view on how we move
forward what is your party policy on
immigration just to just to have caps
that will work so the Teresa Mays
immigration policy is net never worked
they've tried to implement and they just
haven't haven't basically gone hard
enough at it you just need to reduce
immigration you need to reduce net
migration and gross the gross figure is
the is the finger that I want to go near
because you know the whole of business
and the cultural media is lined up to be
pro and so he put any limit on it you've
got massive kickback but but that's what
is required you've got to have
sufficient but not too much right well
that is just out to do as a racist to
everybody watching this because that's
the way this you're going goes right
fine yeah I know that make there's an
immigrant that makes no sense to me but
somehow talking about what you just said
which is we have to reduce immigration
yeah bang race is done you've got to
detoxify some of these things I think
you can't I mean Eric conference very
good on this I mean these are normal
talking about this ought to be
detoxified as much as you want to talk
about transport policy or something it's
a legitimate thing to talk about making
boring he just you know said quite
inflammatory comments crazy no I don't
know I'm I'm a little bit worried about
that I think it's I think that's not
helpful yeah
I wanted to talk about centrism and I'll
try and get it in here look so what is
what is what is centrism it's
representing a mainstream view which is
all we're doing by the way
now if the things that we talk about on
the family community immigration or the
European Union our mainstream opinions I
would say they're centrist opinions and
I would say that if you know cultural
elites think differently well that's not
a centrist opinion I mean that sucker
you can have that opinion but it ain't
centrist it's not you can't and actually
you know chukkas group and you know the
change UK people are going around and
obviously the BBC loves them everything
that they're going around saying they're
centrist I don't know I'm not sure you
know what you're saying you're saying
you want to dishonor the biggest
democratic vote in British history is
that is that a centrist so it's weird I
mean that's like to me that's that's a
mask slipping and it's not you know it's
not a good moment it's not and I do I
reject that this is why people say you
know the SDP is a centrist party it is
it is but it I'm not I'm not wanting
macron or Tony Blair or you know chucker
to join our party
well they're hyper liberals exactly yeah
not necessarily personally anything
wrong with liberals but they are hyper
liberal yes that's what they know
they're not centrist I mean the
counter-argument and it's something I've
been thinking about recently the
counter-argument to the idea that we
must always do what the people want it
would be you know hanging or you know
getting rid of nuclear power stations
because people are afraid of them blow
yeah stuff like that
so what do you say to someone and good
look the people know broadly what they
want but it is the job of experts to
come in and you know take care of things
and make these thing the expertise
things are really a really interesting
thing because obviously go made that
point and he was slammed you know and it
became a sort of brags that remain
remain rock is all obviously all leave
vote as a stupid you know we don't
listen to experts and so on but there
are some really interesting fine-grained
philosophical ideas to be had on that
mat there's a demonstrate macro
expertise and micro so on micro you know
an engineer or someone flying a plane or
a core course I mean that's micro
expertise and exists it really you can
but and the reason its expertise you can
rely on it you can rely on it macro no I
don't think so
macroeconomics is in crisis literally
they're all over the place I mean it's a
wonderful discipline you know to my kids
you know one didn't economics agreement
ones doing one now and but it's in
crisis it is not you can't say that you
have macro expertise that could that
could say where we are with predictive
accuracy you know six months they're
quite good at three months Ashley but
[Laughter]
they're really really poor on on
predicting anything further out and
Ashley go blessing was it was just
making that point because he's talking
about the imf's and you know osed
predictions which was a legitimate thing
to say so you know could it you know
doesn't mean you're ignoring expert no
not generally Taleb Nassim Taleb makes
great great points on this and he's you
know he's an odd figure combs really but
he's like you don't go on his Twitter
now I stay away from now I occasionally
look at it I have following be occasion
look at it but is but it isn't his
contribution to intellectual life is
it's great about two months ago I was
walking down Victoria Embankment and I
saw him walking down I stopped him and
said hello and said I was a big fan and
he was there with his agent spoke for a
for a few minutes and I didn't get a
selfie anyway yes so yeah so the
expertise yeah in its in its in its
proper realm it's it's reliable but take
my point about hanging which i think is
a good example where it's not so much
about expertise but it's a sense that
maybe
we need someone in a position in a cool
calm and collected place where cool calm
and collected people come together watch
Teresa fight the people can't who are
wise heads sitting in Parliament
deliberating on these great matters come
together and ignore our worst instincts
yeah in a sense because hanging is an
issue where the majority of the British
probably perfectly support that right or
have done for a while it's below 50%
know you used to be higher but let's say
let's say it's around 50% or a small
majority maybe it's not hanging maybe
it's just the death penalty maybe you
phrase it like that yes people would
support it right and maybe that's an
issue in which we just need someone to
go no come on guys we don't need to go
that far right so my point is do we
always have to do what the people want
in everything no I don't think I'd
concede on on that point actually I
think some people when we sort of re
putting the the philosophical base of
the SDP together some people are quite
keen on direct democracy I'm not
actually I think if you if you have if
you're if it votes it match seats which
they don't
if votes much see you don't need that
I'm particularly if you have seats that
are connected to a physical you know jog
Rafi to keep the link between voters and
you know so am I in favor of having to
you know votes on the death penalty
no and III couldn't I mean I'm totally
and utterly against the idea of the
death penalty so I would have to say
even if and I'll be honest even if 55%
of people want to know I wouldn't be
basically right
and so that's brexit isn't it some
people would make that point that you
could do they could do but it but the
the difference is that honor on a on a
tiny micro but lethal question for an
individual is that is that equivalent to
asking how your government how your
state is governed
I mean break the breaks that is the
biggest question of our political lives
now
because it is the biggest question I
mean we haven't we talked about you know
that the nation-state as an idea is
diminished very very diminished if you
speak to a a new graduate at a modern
University in Britain fail disparage
nationalism they will do it 90% of them
probably yeah they will disparage it
they what they had what they're not
seeing is the side of the positive side
of convening national solidarity to do
stuff together yeah so we're in it
together and they also don't see this
the phony side of the you not having
that now
let's so I love it that we've got 50
minutes and it's only really now that
we've touched on brexit I was keeping an
eye to see how long it would take what
we are now is I think is in a position
like we said political crisis yeah if
you were the Prime Minister how would
you deal with brixon it's all for
question because that you wouldn't got
you wouldn't have what wanted to get
here but up that's I would say leave
without deal no that's the only because
I think they see anything that respects
it I think personally her her actual
deal that the deal that she has that
Barney a male may deal is worse and
staying in I me you're a skeptic I want
to leave but I would sooner stay in than
vote for that deal that is a dreadful
dreadful deal um you can't there are
some advantages to staying in but you
can't give those advantages up without
having the advantages of leaving and so
her deal has none of the advantages of
leaving you don't get your own trade
policy you don't know how you'll ever
get out of the customs union if you if
you can dreadful so the only option
actually where we are we wouldn't have
wanted to get here but the only option
is actually leaving without a deal but
by the way I don't think it's going to
happen I really think I think the
establishment of pudding breaks it into
a sort of killing zone now and I think
this is why I objected to the European
relations so much because it's a slow
where the public down get that sort of
you know the the soft brexit hard brexit
narrative where them down don't honor it
put it into a you know negotiated a
terrible deal that which the Commons
everyone knows couldn't because the
various on the on the mass couldn't
support then you know get to the next
stage by having European parlance don't
get the you to give you a longer delay
which they'll do you I mean there's
actually there's a busted flush now give
you any delay you want now as long as
you stay in them you know continue the
status grow they'll just give us as much
time because every single vote the
European Union has had on the treaties
previously no Greece were actually that
was about austerity but a Holland France
Denmark twice Ireland twice the standard
way of doing it is to say sorry wrong
result vote again and I thought we were
different I thought I and that's been
the real the real tragedy the real
realization is that we thought we were
different to any we're not the the elite
here are doing it to us exactly the same
that's the proper way of doing it he
just eventually make us wait again and
the only question is do they are they're
gonna have to do that or you do get some
sort of false brexit that gets through
and but I incident if they do that I
don't think that public gonna be good
convinced but if you get the worst
referendum that could have is maze deal
or stay in so thought it's staying grasp
or stay in proper that would be even
worse according to what you're saying
you see Frances and I both voted remain
because I'm a good people there we go
it's a running joke on the show we we
have people saying when are you gonna
start selling t-shirts with that slogan
we don't actually think that way in fact
both of us have a lot of reservations
about what's happened since brexit and I
particularly feel like if if we got to a
point where we had a second referendum
and it was either leave with no deal or
remain I would vote to leave with no
deal yeah my only concern with that is
how damaging is that going to be because
I'll be honest with you I think
democracy is much more important than
economics yeah them as well so if we
were to leave and suffer some economic
disruption in the short term I'm
comfortable with that but I'm not so
comfortable
the idea that we leave and destroy our
economy for 20 years that would be it
yeah I don't think that's I mean I just
don't genuinely don't believe that's in
the offing I mean a modern economy that
wants things with its own currency will
in getting them I mean you will end up
getting suppliers in their mind will be
that supplier but they will be a
supplier in the world will supply your
stuff I don't buy I think there will be
a transition and there will be some
turbulence and no doubt about it you
wouldn't want to have got to a situation
where you've had to do No Deal but we're
here and if it happens out in the
country would would you know it would
have probably 12 months of readjustment
certain industries will suffer I mean I
think certain manufacturing industries
long supply lines without there's gonna
be turbulence there and the economics of
that could change but that's an
adaptation and as a as opposed on the
other side of the balance sheet
destroying people's faith and democracy
for a generation that's how worth is
that worth it for a theoretically you
know quarter percent of GDP for a few
years I don't buy it
and so that's yeah that's where we are I
think the I think the the case I miss a
point we're making a new deck the case
for rejecting the European Union as its
structured on democratic grounds is
incredibly strong I mean it's really
really strong if you're a fully
integrated eurozone state like Portugal
or Holland or there are five major
important policy areas which your voters
can't touch so you know if you say if I
can remember the monetary policy fiscal
policy trade policy immigration and dust
Rapala see that's your normal Portuguese
you can't elect a politician that can
touch that you can and that's a
desperate situation now the usual
trade-off is that if things are going so
well economically in whistle you know
bellies is so full will put up with that
it's a bit like in China people talk
about you know why isn't there more
pressure for democracy in China well the
the
theory is that if China grows 8% people
their mind you know and that's the sort
of deal trouble with the eurozone it it
doesn't I mean II got mass unemployment
you've got mass unemployment in the
South the eurozone isn't growing a lot
of large economies like Italy I've gone
as a decline um so it isn't working
economically and yet voters don't have a
purchase can't get a handle on any of
these things and in pub discussions are
trying because I drink with a couple of
remain as every Friday
they're nice remain it's the Democrats
like you Democratic remainder so you I
think if they were push come to shove
would probably on a future referendum
but a point the best point I could ever
make to them is it's just line up beer
glasses or cups and call them monetary
policy and just try and touch them try
and get them so if you're a normal voter
in the year you can't touch it and what
that means is it means that those are
really really massive things have been
decided pre politically as devastating
that's that means that it's all been
wrapped up you know it's all been
wrapped up before you even get anywhere
near it and that can't happen by
accident it's it's deliberate thing I
mean is structured like that and it's
very sad that it's like that but it is
like that and I don't you know I don't
want the eurozone to crash in flames and
things but it won't last forever because
it can't it's not a good system so I
think it's a bit like your railways you
know when when the people with the
little trains you know running I'm
tangoing trouble the state has to pick
up the pieces and actually in Europe
when the Euro project which is a utopian
1950s project when it falls down the
nation-states will be there too as the
only entities that could pick up and
reconvene stuff and do stuff that will
happen alright well we've got time for
one last question and the question that
we always ask is what is a one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be I'm
gonna say civilized tolerance or
civilized toleration of differences
I refuse to hear this well here we go so
we hear at first
so there's a sort of I talked about the
sort of social justice mania that we're
going through and part of that you have
you have sort of parity make maniacs or
look at any domain whether it's sandwich
shops and Soho or I'm joking but you
know footsie boards any category they go
crazy if if there's not equal absolute
proportionality between every group you
can think of you know men women or
different ethnic minorities whatever o
or different classes and they just go
crazy you know and it's so as if as if
the end game of the of the project
they're they're doing will be that we
will get absolute 50/50 parity across
all domains and I would say a social
democratic ethic would be in an open and
tolerant society there will be some
differences you know the will be and
we're gonna have to live with them and
we're gonna have to be live with them
instead of civilized toleration you
won't get total you want equality and
some of the you know social does is
important value but the idea that you're
gonna get total parity is is juvenile
and I don't think it's actually even
desirable in the people make different
choices in life and that's fine and I
think if we if we have this civilized
toleration we will be better better off
for it fantastic well if anyone wants to
follow you on twitter you're at know so
bad will you'll find me William clusen
SDP and how can if people really enjoyed
this conversation and I thought this is
the party for me how can they get
involved St Peter org have a look and
and I I think the biggest thing I would
allege people do is to read the new
declaration because that's the
philosophical side and if you like it
think about joining and get part of it
if you don't fantastic well thank you
very much for coming on it's been a
pleasure absolute pleasure as always
follow us at trigger pod on all the
social media subscribe to the YouTube
channel you can listen to this as a
podcast as many of you will know and the
thing that Francis has been pointing out
and we've been hearing a lot of is on
YouTube we've had people
being unsubscribed including repeatedly
from our channel we don't know why could
it be that we have honest conversations
with interesting people I don't know
anyway if that's you if you've been a
subscribed let us know and we'll keep
hammering YouTube and they will do
nothing about it yet again and it's also
if you like it you don't feel
comfortable tweeting about it or
retweeting just tell a friend spread the
word spread the hate guys turned we will
see you next week in a week
[Music]